kelly clarkson breaks down in tears
blake shelton opens up about his
proposal fears
it literally is an emotional
rollercoaster on the voice as the
coaches get ready for tonight's finale
all right let's start with kelly who was
overcome by a motion
[Music]
[Applause]
um
i needed that song everybody needs that
message right now
kelly cried twice on the voice at first
after her finalist dez's performance
i'm so proud to get get to be her coach
and while coaching her in rehearsal
[Music]
kelly who's in the middle of a nasty
divorce from her husband of seven years
also fought back tears with garth brooks
on her talk show yesterday
kelly told garth his song the dance is
helping her cope with the painful
breakup
there's a lot of grief and a lot of loss
and a lot of change especially for kids
meanwhile fellow coach gwen stefani
broke news about blake's proposal on
kelly's show today
she says blake surprised her next to the
fireplace
blake basically like was getting down on
his knees to do a fire and he goes hey
can you look in that cabinet over there
and get me
get me a fire starter so i opened the
cabinet and there was like a ring in a
box and i was like
what are you serious i had that ring
in the compartment on my door of my
truck
for about a week and i kept thinking man
somebody's gonna hit the jackpot
whenever i
drop this thing out of my
the truck performed together for the
first time since their engagement last
night on the voice
and these two are getting creative for
christmas we're gonna do some
outdoor gift exchange like one family
member like
at a time coming by we decorated this
week and
next week is going to be a little
oklahoma time
even though it was a really hard year
for everyone there was a lot of silver
lining and
a lot of great things that happened in
my personal life
you